[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout petit fou de sa belle quel est le
rapport entre cette boîte de tisanes et
cette plante médicinale impôts grand
consommateur de tisane j'avais
l'habitude d'acheter ces petits sachets
vous savez ce avec la ficelle que l'on
30 dans l'eau bon mais ça c'était avant
il ya deux ans à mon retour en
guadeloupe je parcourais le jardin de ma
mère et je découvre un véritable trésor
il y avait là là juste devant moi puis
d'une quarantaine de plantes médicinales
et aromatiques et c'est là que j'ai eu
le déclic
pourquoi y acheter de la tisane dont je
connais ni la qualité ni l'origine
pourquoi j'irai acheter de la menthe qui
sort de la chine ou de l'europe de l'est
bonjour l'empreinte carbone tous les
matins si la fête
je me prépare en utilisant différentes
pour avoir ma médecine traditionnelle à
proximité j'ai commencé par vous tuerez
toutes ces plantes médicinales d'un
dépôt
tenez 10 g de marjolaine et 10 g de
chicorée pour un litre d'eau permettra à
votre bébé de trouver facilement le
sommeil
et pour ne pas ressembler à un certain
temps guy j'ai ensuite déménagé et dans
ma nouvelle maison
j'ai réalisé mon rêve en créant le
jardin rêvons une contraction de deux
prénoms vraiment ma mère et ils vont le
mien mon concept c'est de planter de
cultiver en pot
les plantes médicinales aromatiques mais
fruits et légumes
ce concept en fait il est adaptable à
toutes les surfaces en passant du balcon
jusqu'aux champs les avantages sont
multiples pour la cueillette pour les
enfants ils n'ont pas besoin de
m'appeler boumediene papier ou papa
viens on va chercher des trucs pendant
l'échelle ensuite pour déménager mais
toujours pas de problème il suffit que
je prenne mes arbres fruitiers
je les emmène avec moi lebègue ma grand
mère auquel je tiens tant le sel la
vaisselle en cas de cyclone mais
toujours pas de problème la baie de
petite taille non moins de prise au vent
en cas de grosses rafales la plante va
se coucher et le tronc ne va pas se
casser
il suffit simplement de remettre le pot
en place et c'est reparti
mon jardin en fait à retrouver son éclat
seulement au bout de deux mois
n'est ce pas là une forme de résilience
et sera ordinaire combien de temps
va-t-il falloir que j'attende pour
manger la première manche je pense une
question vous avez peut-être nous
demander en fait en pleine terre il faut
compter minimum 3 ans en pot vous pouvez
commencer à manger vos manques dès la
première année de fructification grâce
au stress hydrique vous gagné entre 1 et
5 ans sur la fructification
le cs québec en fait c'est un manque
d'eau après une forte pire de chaleur la
plante va penser qu'elle va mourir et va
mettre en place une stratégie pour
fleurir ainsi s'assurer une descendance
exemple de fructification en 2014
j'ai fait l'acquisition de manguiers
donc cette année de 2014 j'ai récolté
demande en 2015 15 membres en 2016 30
manque
tenez vous bien en 2017 de récolte de
deux fois 60 mais à chaque fois
puis vous serez un accord aussi avec le
ms qui recommande de manger cinq fruits
et légumes par jour serait quand j'ai
des invités
il suffit simplement que je tend le bras
dans le jardin pour assurer une bonne
dégustation
et puis cultiver ces plantes aromatiques
ses fruits et ses légumes en pot c'est
aussi s'intéresser aux intéressés ses
enfants au goût et au respect de
l'environnement
nous avons tous des enfants des ados qui
sont souvent vautrer dans leur canapé
avec leurs engins connectés savait se
disent j'ai une petite faim je vais
chercher quelque chose dans le frigo
j'ouvre le frigo je prends je mange et
je reviens sur le canapé
rapprochons-nous de la nature l'entente
nous propose un arbre ça nous permettra
de les arroser de
entretenir de les désarmer manuellement
c'est mon cas en ce moment nous sommes
tous très peu stressé alors prenons le
temps ralentit son remplaçant le futile
par l'essentiel adopté ce concept c'est
aussi de manger mieux de dépenser moins
de réduire aussi votre impact carbone
souvenez quelques astuces pour que vous
puissiez vous aussi votre plantation
vous allez choisir un pot de 90 minimum
dans lequel vous avez peu paraît en bon
substrat composé de 80 % de terre
végétale 15% de sable et 5% de calcaire
avec un soupçon de terreau le tout
arrosé tous les jours avec amour sans
oublier un apport en engrais tous les
deux mois un haga organique ou minérale
pour le la taille des arbres c'est vrai
que dans le bassin caribéen ne sommes
pas trop habitués à cela alors moi je
vais vous conseiller de faire la tête à
partir du 1er septembre jusqu'au 15
décembre
ensuite votre arbre est à l'étroit dans
son pot même pas de problème il suffit
simplement de le transférer dans un pot
un peu plus grand en rajoutant un peu de
substrats mais attention je vous
conseille de teillé aussi quelques
branches peu là puissent mieux repartir
optez aussi pour une citerne à eau ça
vous permettra de recycler l'eau de
pluie d'être autonome un investissement
d'être rentable vous pouvez aussi
fabriquer votre propre compost à partir
de vos déchets ménagers c'est un
fertilisant gratuit dans le jardin
il ya quelques variétés que je vais vous
présenter comme les pommes à la can et
pour moi car c'est un fruit qui est très
délicieux très rafraîchissant j'ai le
rouge le blanc vous connaissez le vert
où il a un peu plus sucré ensuite les
pommes sur est épandu sur est on
l'appelle aussi juge une aussi grosse
qu'une pointe de cythère des pauvres
d'acidité et aussi qu'aucune pommes les
mangues mon jardin pour 7 8 variétés
dont la mangeuse est appelé aussi mangue
égyptienne et puis aussi le veut donc à
dia qui nous vient d'australie
très prisée des grands chefs ce citron
est vraiment extraordinaire
ensuite vous avez le free miraculeux
alors lui il est très étonnant et gras
sucrés et tout ce qui est acide ainsi un
citron devient aussi doux qu'une cité
une citronnade et puis vous avez les
pipelines jaboticaba c'est un colis
flore c'est à dire un arbre qui va
porter les fruits sur le tronc ou les
branches comme le kaka drogba exemple et
vous avez les pitas bon jardin possède
cinq variétés de pete ailleurs donc
quatre à féconder
je choisis plutôt le soir pour faire ma
fécondation parce qu'à partir de 5
heures du matin savez quoi les abeilles
viennent faire le plein du problème donc
j'essaie de passer avant eux
mais avant d'en arriver là j'ai fait de
nombreux essais et
j'ai planté planté et planter encore et
moi mais je me suis bien planté comme
total ont d'ailleurs grâce à la magie du
jardin révélant des liens se sont créés
petit à petit mais des africains pau ont
suscité la curiosité et a fait
énormément d'adeptes aujourd'hui je fais
des conférences
j'interviens dans le milieu scolaire les
écoles les collèges pour perpétuer le
savoir comprenez bien que le manque de
surfaces n'est pas un obstacle et si on
s'y mettait tous qu'est ce que cela
changerait pour le monde me direz vous
ben de se rapprocher de l'autosuffisance
alimentaire
vous qui adorez les fruits vous n'aurez
aucune excuse pour ne pas adopter ce
concept
alors à vous de jouer
on sait pas plus
je n'avais aucune connaissance dans ce
domaine j'ai réussi à faire pousser à
faire fructifier ces arbres alors
maintenant oser c'est bon pour votre
santé c'est bon pour votre moral c'est
bon pour la planète et imaginons un
instant que des milliers de jardins
vivant sur la terre où chacun pourrait
s'échanger des graines des plants leurs
récoltes
n'est ce pas là un beau projet de
société mais alors maintenant oser et
rêvons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]